we got saved we got a third season
johnna johnston maria peterson eric
aguiard
ty lainey says buffy jacob says this
show is brilliant
and needs to be saved well guess what i
agree you know who else agreed
peacock tv it is brilliant we have the
most amazing writers we have the most
amazing fans like you
you're right it is brilliant and it has
been saved because of people like you
thank you buffy annie rich writes this
show is too funny to end
especially without the finale it
deserves you're right i mean what can i
say
uh i agree it makes me laugh so i'm glad
it makes you laugh too
hi annie thank you so much for your
laughs and thank you for keeping us in
the classroom
i hope you continue to enjoy our show
dara cosby quality comedy needs to be
supported
thank you ap bio is a gem thank you
bring on season three and then some and
then some thank you thank you thank you
thank you so much for your support i'm
gonna really like season three
please enjoy dhaba tai lani says
this is one of the greatest shows on
television thank you
season two even ended in such an
amazingly perfect way for an awesome
season
three if you thought season two ended
perfectly
i cannot i i wish i could see
your face as you streamed all the
episodes of season three
erica aguiar says this show is fantastic
not many like it and the students crack
me up do you have a favorite student
it's okay i know it's heather she's my
favorite student too
well thank you we do our best it's not
us this is all from you know mike
o'brien and the writers brains
shout out to my student cast i love all
you guys and we have the best time
making this show so thank you erica
brian price says
ap bio is definitely one of the best
things on tv right now
funny story lines and great characters
ah yes i totally agree brian i think
the writers on the show michael bryant
everyone it is
they are so talented and write the
funniest stuff
thanks ryan thank you we think so too
if you bio feels really really special
but it's
mostly special because we have fans like
you thank you so much friend
thank you so much for uh petitioning for
us and i'm really glad that
someone gets the point of all this
madness thank you
for being a fan we couldn't do it
without you guys get ready it's coming
back
thank you for signing we're all gonna
watch season three so we get a season
four
until we get a season five and who knows
what's coming down the pike
it's a show that is an absolute pleasure
to work on so thanks to you guys i get
to keep working on it season three
peacock can't wait for you guys
you